La diabetes mellitus ha flagelado
el mundo desarrollado;
se estima que 400 millones de personas
en todo el mundo sufren esta enfermedad,
y se predice un 50% más
en el plazo de 20 años.
Sus primeros síntomas, sed y
aumento de grandes volúmenes de orina,
se reconocieron ya en 1500 aC en Egipto.
Aunque el término diabetes,
que significa "pasar a través",
lo utilizó por primera vez en 250 aC
el médico griego Apolonio de Memphis,
las diabetes tipo 1 y tipo 2,
asociadas, respectivamente,
con la juventud y la obesidad,
se identificaron
como enfermedades separadas
por médicos de India
hacia el siglo V aC.
Pero a pesar de conocerse la enfermedad,
el diagnóstico de la diabetes
siguió siendo equivalente a una sentencia
de muerte hasta principios del siglo XX,
ya que no se conocía qué la causaba.
Lo que cambió esta situación calamitosa
fue la ayuda del compañero animal
de siempre de la humanidad:
canis lupus familiaris, domesticado de
lobos grises hace miles de años.
En 1890, los científicos alemanes
von Mering y Minkowski
demostraron que
la extirpación del páncreas de un perro
provocaba que se desarrollan
todos los síntomas de la diabetes,
estableciendo así el papel central
del órgano en la enfermedad.
Sin embargo, el mecanismo exacto de
cómo ocurría fue un misterio hasta 1920
cuando un joven cirujano canadiense
llamado Frederick Banting
y su estudiante, Charles Best,
desarrollaron los hallazgos
de sus colegas alemanes.
Trabajando con el profesor Macleod
de la Universidad de Toronto,
confirmaron que el páncreas
era responsable
de la regulación de la glucosa en sangre,
y trataron con éxito a los perros diabéticos
inyectándoles un extracto
que habían preparado
a partir de tejido pancreático.
En 1922, los investigadores
que trabajan con el bioquímico James Collip
pudieron desarrollar
un extracto de páncreas vacuno
para el primer tratamiento de
un niño diabético de 14 años,
seguido de seis pacientes más.
El proceso de fabricación de este extracto,
ahora conocido como insulina,
finalmente se entregó a una empresa farmacéutica
que fabrica los diferentes tipos
de insulina inyectable de hoy.
Banting y Macleod recibieron
el Premio Nobel de Medicina
en 1923 por su descubrimiento.
Pero Banting decidió compartir
su parte con Charles Best,
por su ayuda en los estudios iniciales
que involucraron a perros.
Pero aunque la experimentación médica
con animales sigue siendo controvertida,
en este caso al menos,
no fue solo una explotación de perros
para necesidades humanas.
Los perros desarrollan diabetes
a razón de dos casos por cada 1000 perros,
casi la misma que la de
los seres humanos de menos de 20.
La mayoría de los casos caninos
son de la diabetes tipo 1,
similar al tipo que
desarrollan los niños pequeños
tras la destrucción del páncreas
por el sistema inmunológico.
Los estudios genéticos
han demostrado que
la enfermedad canina tiene muchas
características similares a la humana.
Esto ha permitido a los veterinarios
a su vez cambiar la situación,
utilizando con éxito la insulina
para tratar la diabetes
por los últimos 60 años
en el mejor amigo del hombre.
Muchos dueños de perros se comprometen
a controlar la diabetes de sus perros
con insulina inyectada dos veces al día,
la alimentación regulada,
y los análisis de sangre periódicos
utilizando los mismos monitores de glucosa
caseros utilizados por pacientes humanos.
Y si la insulina de cerdo purificada
utilizada comúnmente para perros
no funciona para un perro en particular,
el veterinario puede incluso
formular insulina humana,
cerrando el círculo.
Después de todo lo que los perros
han hecho por nosotros por siglos,
incluyendo su papel en
un descubrimiento médico
que ha salvado
innumerables vidas humanas,
utilizar el mismo conocimiento
para ayudarles
es lo mínimo que podemos hacer.